jahrelang hinter gitter die russische
justiz verurteilt den kreml-kritiker
alexej nawalny angeblich oder gegen
bewährungsauflagen verstoßen haben
eine wagenladung hoffnung als erstes
europäisches land setzt ungarn auf den
russischen impfstoff sputnik wie und
neue studien sagen der wirkt ziemlich
gut und zurück in die zukunft ein halbes
jahrhundert nach der ersten landung
wollen die amerikaner wieder auf den
mond auch mit deutscher hilfe
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu unserem
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
norbert lehmann ist auch wieder dabei
für den einen schönen guten abend auch
von mir
alexej nawalny gilt als populärster
kritiker von kremlchef putin auch heute
vor gericht zeigte er sich unbeeindruckt
hauptziel dieses prozesses gegen ihn sei
es millionen menschen angst einzujagen
trotz heftiger proteste in russland und
auch im ausland wurde der 44 jährige
soeben zu dreieinhalb jahren gefängnis
verurteilt ein knappes jahr davon wird
von der untersuchungshaft angerechnet
in einem glaskasten im moskauer
stadtgericht verfolgten die die anhörung
er soll gegen bewährungsauflagen aus
einem früheren verfahren verstoßen haben
die konnte er allerdings auch gar nicht
erfüllen weil er nach einem anschlag mit
einem nervengift fast fünf wochen in der
charité in berlin behandelt wurde
aus moskau axel stopp es hatte sich
abgezeichnet dass alexej nawalny ins
gefängnis muss zwei jahre und acht
monate haft warten jetzt auf ihn
scheinbar teilnahmslos hört sich navalny
die urteilsverkündung an seine frau
sitzt unter den zuhörern
dies ist ein politischer prozess der
mensch wurde in russland vergiftet aber
dieses verbrechen untersucht man nicht
der mensch kommt nach russland zurück
und man wirft ihnen ins gefängnis und
verklagte das ist ein prozess ohne
rechtsgrundlage ein mann sitzt ohne
grund in haft vor dem moskauer
stadtgericht trat navalny selbstbewusst
auf mit einer mischung aus verteidigung
und politische rede eine tonaufnahme das
wichtigste an diesem prozess ist eine
gewaltige anzahl von menschen
einzuschüchtern
dies funktioniert so einen sperrt man
ein um millionen angst zu machen
er habe gegen seine bewährungsauflagen
verstoßen befand das gericht als er in
deutschland war und sich vom anschlag
erholte hätte er sich bei der polizei
melden müssen die auflage stammt aus
einer alten verurteilung die damals
schon international scharf kritisiert
worden war
jetzt wird aus einem alten urteil eine
lange haftstrafe
rund 300 festnahmen gab es im lauf des
tages einige navalny unterstützer waren
gekommen um vor dem gericht zu
demonstrieren
der staat aber machte mehr als deutlich
klar störungen waren auch heute
unerwünscht und vor dem gericht steht
für uns christian senn wie von den
behörden vorgeschrieben als journalist
mit weste gekennzeichnet christian gab
es überhaupt noch hoffnung dass
navarrete freikommt nein die hoffnung
waren nicht sehr groß also das urteil
ist so ausgefallen wie das navis
anhänger befürchtet hatten letztendlich
ist es so dass mit abzug des hausarrest
er für zwei jahre und acht monate in ein
straflager muss hier rund um das gericht
gab es heute ein riesiges
sicherheitsaufgebot alles war weiträumig
abgesperrt nur wenige anhänger hatten
versucht noch vor prozessbeginn zum
gerichtsgebäude zu kommen um navalny zu
unterstützen und die solidarität zu
zeigen
doch die sicherheitskräfte haben gezeigt
was sie davon halten nämlich gar nichts
es gab hunderte festnahmen die letzten
zahlen liegen bei 354 andere
demonstranten wurden über den tag
vertrieben das zum schluss dann nun auch
polizisten polizisten spezialkräfte und
journalisten hier waren was bedeutet
diese strafe für die protestbewegung
zeigt die einschüchterung wirkung
also das entsetzen bei navis anhängern
ist natürlich groß dass diese
befürchtung jetzt eingetreten ist
bei den demonstrationen die wir die
letzten wochen gesehen haben ist es
unterschiedlich einige gehen auf die
straße und unterstützender wahrnehmen
andere menschen die demonstrieren folgen
eben nicht unmittelbar die haben ihre
eigenen themen warum sie auf die straße
gehen da geht es um korruption da geht
es um die ihrer meinung nach jährige
macht elite und vor allem sind es
proteste gegen präsident putin
dabei ist ihm hat für den abend für
heute abend direkt nach dem urteil die
menschen dazu aufgerufen auf die straße
zu gehen in die nähe des kreml und wir
müssen jetzt mal über den abend
beobachten was sich da entwickelt
dankeschön für den moment macht moskau
christiansen war das schauen wir auf die
aktuellen corona infektionszahlen die
sind weiter rückläufig die positive
entwicklung der vergangenen tage setzt
sich fort
laut robert-koch-institut meldeten die
gesundheitsämter am morgen 6114 neue
fälle das sind gut 300 weniger als am
dienstag vor einer woche
außerdem wurden 861 weitere todesfälle
in zusammenhang mit coop 19 registriert
wie kann das impfen in deutschland
schneller und besser werden diese frage
debattierten bund länder und
pharmavertreter auf dem impfgipfel
gestern das ergebnis wenig konkretes und
die feststellung die nächsten wochen
wird der impfstoff knapp bleiben
patricia wiedemeier hat mehr über fünf
stunden dauerte gestern der impf gipfel
im kanzleramt am abend dann die bittere
erkenntnis eine kurzfristige besserung
ist nicht in sicht von nach harten
wochen der knappheit ist die rede
gipfel gestern hat wirklich klarheit
gebracht aber eben auch ernüchterung
zusätzlich kapazitäten jetzt scheinen
traum möglich zu sein
die kanzlerin verteidigte in der ard das
europäische vorgehen nicht auf no
zulassungen zu setzen wie zum beispiel
die usa und großbritannien
warum sind die usa schneller warum es
israel schneller warm ist großbritannien
schneller das wohnt ein natürlich wir
haben uns entschieden dass wir das
kunstlicht bei der europäischen medizin
agentur machen wollen weil wir auch
bleiben das war kein fehler
wir sind auf das vertrauen an
gewesen vertrauen ja aber das heißt es
gibt vorläufig kaum veränderungen bei
der liefermenge dafür aber wohl bei der
prioritätenliste
da der impfstoff von astrazeneca in
deutschland nur für menschen unter 65
zugelassen ist könnten jüngere also
medizinisches personal und auch
risikopatienten in die erste gruppe
nachrücken und früher geimpft werden
das zumindest sieht ein entwurf des
gesundheitsministeriums vor demnach
sollen einzelne krankheitsbilder den
priorität gruppen angepasst werden
ich bin der auffassung dass wir über die
prioritäten des impfens noch mal neu
nachdenken müssen und die ständige
impfkommission sollte einen neuen
vorschlag unterbreiten was ich mir
persönlich gewünscht hätte ist wäre auch
eine weitere berücksichtigung von
menschen die in bereichen tätig sind wo
sie täglich eben auch kontakte haben im
öffentlichen interesse dass es zum
beispiel bei mehreren lehrern bei
erzieherinnen erzieher der fall
es bleiben viele offene fragen die
bundesregierung hält dennoch an ihrem
versprechen fest bis zum ende des
sommers allen die wollen ein impfangebot
zu machen
von anfang an war klar dass nach einer
prioritätenliste nach einer rangfolge
geimpft wird im moment ist die gruppe
eins dran dazu zählen unter anderem
bewohner und mitarbeiter in pflegeheimen
alle über 80 jährigen und personal auf
intensivstationen in notaufnahmen und
rettungsdiensten schwerkranke menschen
die zu hause betreut werden gehören
bisher nicht dazu
ein junger mann zog dagegen vor gericht
mit erfolg doch niklas meister vincent
cast ist seit einem unfall hals abwärts
gelähmt wie viele schwerbehinderte
menschen gehört der 24-jährige nicht zu
den ersten beiden kategorien für eine
corona impfung obwohl er risikopatient
ist aufgrund meiner hund
querschnittslähmung sondern auch meine
lungenflügel stark betroffen
und im falle einer corona infektion
würde ich beatmungs pflichtig werden und
wer ein schwerer verlauf sehr
wahrscheinlich deshalb ist vincent cast
vor gericht gezogen und hat recht
bekommen
die stadt frankfurt muss nun prüfen ob
er sofort geimpft werden kann
die menschen über 80 aktuelle in den
impfzentren für den frankfurter
gesundheitsdezernenten eine schwierige
entscheidung wir müssen diese
einzelfälle berücksichtigen und dafür
brauchen wir ein ordentliches verfahren
in meinen augen brauchen wir auch dazu
dann eine im grunde genommen eine eigene
zahl von impfungen die dafür reserviert
werden ein weiteres problem menschen mit
behinderung die zu hause wohnen fallen
ganz durchs raster und gehen wir uns
wehren uns die ungleichbehandlung von
menschen mit behinderung in
einrichtungen die in der regel zu den
ersten in gruppen gerannt und den
menschen mit behinderungen die ambulant
wohnen bei angehörigen oder ihre pflege
selber organisieren vincent cast
immerhin erhielt heute gute nachrichten
er bekommt morgen die korona impfung
der bedarf an impfstoff ist so groß dass
die bundesregierung sich vorstellen kann
auch den russischen impfstoff sputnik
wie in deutschland einzusetzen
vorausgesetzt europas
arzneimittelbehörde lässt ihn zu ein eu
land wollte darauf nicht warten
ungarn hat sputnik wie im alleingang
zugelassen seit heute wird geliefert
britta hilpert
da rollt die erste ladung bibi nach
ungarn rein die ersten 40.000 von
insgesamt zwei millionen impfdosen aus
russland die verteilung von impfstoffen
geht den ungarn einfach zu langsam
je früher wir unsere verwundbaren
bevölkerungsgruppen so der ungarische
außenminister desto eher können wir
einschränkenden auf das hat sputnik wie
ist der erste corona impfstoff seit
sommer 2020 wird er in russland verimpft
obwohl damals noch klinische tests und
ganz notverordnung lässt sputnik wie nun
zu
bei der wirkstoff bereits eine million
mal ohne große nebenwirkungen verimpft
wurde
damit steht ungarn aus der gemeinsamen
eu impfstrategie aus die note zulassung
kann ein eu mitgliedsstaat erlassen aber
nur unter strikten bedingungen und er
ist selbst haftbar impfstoff für 700
millionen menschen verspricht russland
sputnik wie ist zu über 91 prozent
wirksam so eine studie die heute in der
fachzeitschrift the lancet erschienen
die rohdaten der studie sind aber noch
nicht zugänglich die bräuchte aber die
europäische zulassungsbehörde ema wenn
die immer als europäische
zulassungsbehörde die daten in der
adäquaten form auch bekommt dass sie die
entsprechend prüfen können wie von den
anderen herstellern auch dann sehe ich
aufgrund der daten die wir bis dato
gesehen haben heute eigentlich kein
problem dass das nicht eine zulassung in
europa geben kann
bundeskanzlerin merkel sieht das ähnlich
jeder impfstoff ist in der europäischen
union willkommen aber es wird nur der
zugelassen der von der europäischen
medizin agentur auch die notwendigen
daten bringt das virus kennt keine
grenzen sagt man wenn die daten stimmen
kann das auch für impfstoffe gelten
großbritannien hat nicht nur mit einer
hoch ansteckenden mutation zu kämpfen
jetzt häufen sich auch noch die fälle
der korona variante aus südafrika seit
heute sollen sich daher zehntausende in
mehreren regionen englands schnell tests
unterziehen die hoffnung weitere fälle
schnell entdecken infektionsketten
nachvollziehen
und die ausbreitung der variante
verhindern dabei traut das land um einen
seiner krone helden zur tom moore ist
mit 100 jahren an dem virus gestorben
der weltkriegsveteran hatte 100 runden
mit seinem rollator im heimischen garten
gedreht um spenden für den britischen
gesundheitsdienst zusammen
statt der erhofften tausendpfund bekam
nur rund 33 millionen zusammen
im juli stiegen königin der
selbstzweifel zum vitter zurück nach
deutschland
im sommer 2020 hat es der
milliardenschwere skandal um den
dax-konzern wirecard ans licht gebracht
das versagen der finanzaufsicht bafin
verantwortlich für die behörde ist
bundesfinanzminister scholz der wir
jetzt aufräumen
am freitag musste der bafin-chef seinen
hut nehmen
heute präsentierte stolz weitere pläne
klaus projekt berichtet der skandal
brachte den finanzminister unter druck
nun macht er selbst druck um die reform
bis zum sommer durchs parlament zu
bringen
ich will eine finanzaufsicht mit bissig
will eine harte kontrolle der
finanzmärkte
dass es gut für den finanzmarkt
deutschland und für den schutz der
anlegerinnen und anleger darum geht es
in dem vorschlag eine sogenannte fokus
auf sicht soll unternehmens geflechte
als ganzes kontrollieren und eine
taskforce schnellhardt mit hoheitlichen
befugnissen eingreifen können
dazu besseres und auch mehr personal und
endlich moderne it-systeme das was wir
bisher vor den scholz gehört haben sind
ja nur schlagworte also eine neue ist
bei der bafin einzuführen hatte ich
finde selbstverständlichkeit wer könnte
denn was dagegen haben olaf scholz
erweckt kleine brötchen
wir haben es ja hier mit dem größten
finanzskandal der bundesrepublik zu tun
da reicht es nicht ein bisschen
powerpoint karaoke zu machen mit etwas
was roland berger das
beratungsunternehmen aufgeschrieben hat
was mir beispielsweise zu kurz kommt ist
eine bessere europäische koordination
und wir müssen auch darüber reden ob die
bafin nicht mehr unabhängigkeit
gegenüber dem finanzministerium braucht
die nachfolge von bafin-chef hufe der
freitag seinen rückzug erklärt hatte ist
weiter offen gesucht werde weltweit eine
person die internationale finanzmärkte
verstehe und zugleich die betuliche
bafin reformieren können dürfte vulkan
mehr erneuerbare energien weniger gas
und kohle siemens energy baut um und
will bis 2025 weltweit 7800 stellen
streichen
3000 davon in deutschland betroffen ist
die kraftwerkssparte vor allem
arbeitsplätze in management verwaltung
und vertrieb sind bedroht die deutschen
standorte blieben aber erhalten teilt
siemens energy mit der konzern will
kosten senken
auch wenn er derzeit schwarze zahlen
schreibt etwa durch windkraft von der
erde ins weltall vor knapp 50 jahren
waren zum letzten mal menschen auf dem
mond jetzt laufen vorbereitungen für den
nächsten besuch
artem es heißt die mission der nasa
gelingen soll sie auch dank technik made
in bremen dort neben service und
antriebs module gefertigt
ende des jahres startet der erste
testflug so der plan noch ohne
astronauten aber die sollen folgen mit
dabei wäre auch ein alter bekannter
keine klatsch berichtet so greifbar war
der mond für europa noch nie zusammen
mit den usa kanada russland und japan
hat die europäische weltraumorganisation
esa drei raumschiffe produziert mit dem
raumschiff ryan soll es dann bereits im
nächsten jahr richtung mond gehen
der erste flug wird ohne astronauten
seien aber schon da wird europa mit
dabei sei nicht nur mit dem service
modell sondern auch mit
testeinrichtungen
da geht es um den mond herum das wird
schon sehr bald sein davon aus dass es
spätestens anfang nächsten jahres
stattfindet oben auf dem raumschiff
befindet sich die astronauten kapseln
das europäische service modul versorgt
die besatzung mit sauerstoff und wasser
außerdem sitzt dort der antrieb es wird
in bremen zusammen gebaut wo mit europa
großen anteil an der mission hat einer
der sich erhofft seinen fuß auf den mond
zu setzen alexander gerst der bereits
mit der iss im all war auch sein traum
von der mondfahrt jetzt zum greifen nah
es gibt eben schon drei europäische
service module die volles haar wäre
existieren leister von stützen auch
pakete in den usa mit dem rein raus
hilfe ein
die anderen zwei stehen noch in bremen
in der halle ist fast fertig und durch
geschickt zu werden
auf dem mond ist eine art basisstation
geplant dort sollen mond eigene
bodenschätze verarbeitet werden auf
seiner rückseite sonnenobservatorium
entstehen um tief ins universum zu
schauen
vor rund sechs jahren war ein testflug
bereits erfolgreich in einem jahr soll
nun der nächste schritt zur mond-mission
erfolgen regenfälle und schneeschmelze
sorgen weiter für überschwemmungen und
hochwasser vor allem am rhein
köln rechnet damit dass der pegel morgen
8.30 erreicht damit wäre keine
schifffahrt mehr möglich mit dem verbot
soll auch vermieden werden dass deiche
durch die wellen beschädigt werden
rheinaufwärts bei koblenz ist der
kritische wert bereits überschritten
jetzt zu dir aber achtelfinale im dfb
pokal ja und da muss heute abend
zweitligist paderborn zum erstklassigen
nachbarn dortmund der bvb zwar favorit
aber der sc
der hatte ja zuvor union berlin aus dem
wettbewerb geworfen also
wieder mal so ein pokalspiel das
spannung verspricht mit rückenwind durch
den bundesliga-sieg gegen augsburg geht
der bvb in dieses achtelfinale aber auch
mit respekt vor dem selbstbewussten
zweitligisten
wir wollen vor allem uns treu bleiben da
spielen wollen mutig sein wollen mutig
agieren wollen ergebnis unabhängig
unserem fußball spielen und der ist
intensiv mit hohem tempo und viel
pressing das wissen sie natürlich auch
in dortmund ganz genau
wir müssen da von anfang an bereit sein
gegen zu halten unsere stärken auf den
plätzen bekommen sonst ganz natürlich
schnell in ihre richtung das wollen die
dortmunder auf jeden fall verhindern
denn sie würden nur zu gerne langsam
etwas konstanz in dieser bisher so
unbeständige saison bekommen
spitzentennis in corona zeiten mit
publikum das gibt's in melbourne nächste
woche start der australian open jetzt
quasi die einstimmung aufs
grand-slam-turnier mit dem pickup morgen
erste auftritt der deutschen topspieler
deutschlands nummer eins alexander
zverev hat seine quarantäne hinter sich
und will ab morgen dann das beste daraus
machen mit dem team gegen kanada danach
wartet serbien kein einziger sieg beim
pick-up damals dafür lief es für zverev
anschließend bei den australian open gut
bis ins halbfinale aber vorhersagen
waren in melbourne schwieriger als
diesmal unter corona vorzeichen die
vorbereitung hat gelitten jeder spieler
der nach australien reist muss der 14
tage hotel quarantäne in kauf nehmen als
entschädigung gibt es nun tennis sogar
vor publikum im fast corona freien
australien scheint das machbar
ja und dann ab montag bei den australian
open sind dann pro tag sogar 30.000
zuschauer zugelassen frau kommt bisschen
neid auf vorsicht im norden da gibt es
schnee und glatteis die details hat
gleich erst internen das heute-journal
wie gewohnt von 14 mit christian sievers
danke für ihr interesse wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend sagen
tschüss bis morgen ansinnen ein
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter wie gehabt im norden deutschlands
bleibt es kalt mit schneefall und sonst
ist es deutlich milder und hier kommt
auch wieder neuer regen im tagesverlauf
auf ja und in der nacht gibt es in
diesem rot schraffierten bereich glatt
als durch gefrierenden regen südlich
davon viele wolken mit regen ja und
sonst die temperaturen bei null bis
minus zwei grad im norden und 10 grad im
südwesten deutschlands
morgen am vormittag wandert dieser
schraffierte bereich etwas weiter nach
norden nördlich davon fällt schnee sonst
viele wolken mit regen teils kräftig zum
nachmittag ist es noch etwas weiter
nördlich mit dem glatteis an den küsten
und in schleswig holstein fällt schnee
und dazu gibt es gewitter und sturm aus
dem südwesten dazu viel regen richtig
viel los beim wetter temperaturen
erreichen 1 bis 4 grad im norden 14 grad
im südwesten deutschlands und die
grenzwerte lage bleibt in den nächsten
tagen uns erhalten 1 bis 13 grad am
donnerstag aber immerhin von südwesten
etwas sonnenschein freitag bis 14 und
samstag sogar minus vier bis vierzehn
die grenz wetterlage weitet sich aus ein
schöner abend